hey everyone this is Cameron with motion
science and I am back today with another
tip / trick for motion design and this
one has to do with parallaxing now if
you haven't already checked out my
course on parallaxing it's called beyond
the parallax effect it's at motion
science TV and it really dives deep into
what you can accomplish with the
parallax effect
it goes beyond some of the typical
things you've probably seen on the
Internet so I was approached by a client
to create a interesting shot out of a
photograph with this biker going through
a tunnel and I thought well hey what
better way to create an interesting shot
with a photograph than to use
parallaxing so what I came up with is
this shot right here and if you look at
the shot it looks like this guy is
riding a bike through a tunnel and that
the tunnel is moving past the camera so
that's what I wanted to show you today
is how I created this effect using a
really simple technique inside of After
Effects but you can use it with new core
or whatever motion design program you're
using so what I did is I started with
the photograph in Photoshop I'm not
going to dive in here to what the
process is to cut out an image but
essentially I started with this original
image I duplicated the layer I created a
tunnel where I painted out the biker and
I duplicate the original layer again and
I isolated the biker with a mask so the
two layers I'm going to use are the
tunnel and the biker so once I've got
those all layered up in Photoshop I jump
into After Effects and I bring those
layers into a composition which is right
here now one of the first things I'm
going to do is if i zoom in here you can
see that the
bottom and the bike has been feathered
off and that's because I added a mask
but you can see right there without the
mask it just created a hard kind of
weird edge as I could have fixed this in
Photoshop but anyways I wanted to mask
this off and make it kind of blend
better better into the background so
okay so next thing I did is I took the
background layer and I positioned it
back in z space obviously these are 3d
layers I positioned it back to thousand
pixels which doesn't look like a lot but
we don't need a lot of parallaxing to
sell the effect here I also scaled it up
just slightly so there you go so it's
back in z space by two thousand pixels
but it's scaled up to 112 percent so it
essentially looks like the same
photograph that we originally started
with but there is some Z separation here
so the next thing I'm going to do before
I add any type of camera is I'm going to
take the biker and I'm going to keyframe
the position of the biker I'm going to
set a keyframe here move to the end of
my timeline and most of the time you
think a biker is moving forward well
when I did the shot I can't remember the
actual reasoning behind it but I found
that moving the biker back slightly
actually made the effect look cooler so
it's all by my look here so I'm gonna
move him back in space just by about hot
on those 650 pixels or so actually I
want to do more than that I'm also gonna
skim to the left just slightly so there
you go and we can kind of follow this
line here you can see this light and
dark grey eyes ooh min that could be our
line of perspective so if at 0 we've got
this much space between this line and
the tire if I go to the end here you can
see well he's too far to the left it's
gonna be slightly to the right
so it's not perfect but it's by I here
and so let's remove them there yeah cool
ok so what I did was I brought that pre
comp into another composition which you
see right here I'm going to scale this
composition down to about 25% the photo
that I was provided to me was huge and a
lot of times I work with the original
size of the image in case the the guy
who did the touch-up on the photography
sends me an updated version I can easily
update that layer in Photoshop and
there's not a scaling issue going on I'd
rather scale the full-size image down in
After Effects and work with it that way
now there are some drawbacks to that
After Effects a lot of times has issues
working with really high res files it
slows down your renders your slows down
your your previews but I just prefer to
work that way so anyway so the image is
scaled down now and I'm gonna add a
camera go to layer new camera and got my
presets here but I'm gonna stick with
thirty five-millimeter no depth of field
is needed for this particular shot and
I'm gonna set a keyframe here and I'm
gonna go to the end of the timeline and
you saw there that the biker moves back
in space and I'm gonna go ahead and push
the camera forward just a little bit
probably somewhere in here so the bikers
moving backwards but the camera is
moving forward so let me preview this
okay so here we can see what it's like
by animating the biker and the pre-comp
and adding a slight camera move to the
shot so we've created parallax but it's
still not where I want it to be so the
next trick and this is the cool
parallaxing trick is to use an effect
under distort called optics compensation
and I've applied this to the pre pre
comp spike layer and what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna go to the beginning
I'm gonna set a keyframe I'm gonna go
ahead and turn this up I'm gonna set it
to 50 and the trick here is to hit
reverse lens distortion and I'll show
you what you see how that it see how the
background came at us when I click that
see that that's what reverse lens
distortion does that's how it kind of
like it turns the turns the parallax
effect online I'm also gonna set the
view center so that it's not centered in
the screen but it's centered a little
bit more maybe down in here you can see
how that affects the image but anyways
we're gonna go to the end of the
timeline and we're going to set another
keyframe to 125 and just see that see
how it stretches this is with the effect
and without with without so let me show
you a preview of this so there we go
there's the enhanced parallax effect by
simply adding the optics compensation
distortion filter and one other quick
thing you'll see right at the end of
this that the mountain tunnel here looks
a little you know too stretched for my
taste right at the end so what we can do
is we can add a new solid let's make it
black and then we'll go to the effect
and we'll go to stylize CC vignette and
we'll make this solid a an adjustment
layer
and we'll just increase the vignette so
if I turn the adjustment layer off you
can see sides there I'll just drag the
center point of the vignette to the
right maybe up a little bit and I'll
increase the amount so there so now you
can't see the sides when it stretches
too far out and there we go that's
optics compensation to create the
parallax effect so until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science